thanks for being here oh thank you thank
you so much i usually walk out
i have this like sexy walk out that i do
but i couldn't do it because i was
already placed
yeah yeah i know i i didn't want you
doing the sexy walk out because i
couldn't handle it last time
oh yeah it was a little too much it
tempted me in ways i've never been
tempted so i said this time i want jay
sitting for the interview ahead of time
amazing
no sexy walk for you oh man ever again
missed opportunity
uh i got to ask you a bunch of questions
because i don't know anybody that's
been traveling anywhere you just got
back from
mauritius yes in africa yes
what's it like over there right now uh
it's it's coveted free there's no kovac
they have no covet and mauritius they
have no
covet and mauritius whatever so it's
it's uh
mauritius whatever it's it's so nice to
be able to hug
people and uh so they're hugging and
they're not hugging
uh face touching um whatever
you know i mean eating off your sandwich
you know i mean drinking your juice you
know i did all of that it was so much
fun
you know what i miss is eating off
someone else's plate that's something i
did all the time
very rude but i did it when they don't
ask you just do it
no i just and i would take like mashed
potatoes off someone else's plate no
fork
no fork just my hand that was
that was what i used to do yeah now
everyone's you can't touch my plate
you might have covid i get i'm the same
way
it was nice it was nice over there i
would tell you this though
the the insects out there are insane
okay the
insects the insects out there are like
gangsta
jack like for real like the insects here
in america are like will smith
the insects over there are like 50 cent
but like
not 50 cent now republican 50. we're
talking about
i just got shot in the cheek 50 cent you
know what i mean
i still have the rabbit teeth uh i will
still pop caps in
asses 50 cents you know what i mean so
street cred fitty cent
street credit not wearing like a polo
pullover and
and voting for trump not abercrombie and
fitch trump supporting
50 no that guy not that guy right it was
a freaking centipede
in in my villa and when me and my family
got in the villa
we opened the door and the centipede
just walked out like oh my bad i know
y'all was coming today
[Laughter]
i had you coming tomorrow i apologize oh
my bad people
i didn't clean up you know were you
there
in africa during the u.s elections i was
what was that like to watch those
returns come in oh my goodness
it was tense here in america i don't
know what it's like to be in
africa it's dude it was it was so crazy
and
and the fact that when he finally did
win
uh we were hugging because we could
but here in america you all hugged as
well and you weren't supposed to
no y'all were all outside hugging
kissing eating each other's fries butt
slapping
all of that slapped so many people slap
just
so many all up in the videos this is
like suge night you know
all up in the videos dancing
touching were you not supposed to i know
it was a momentous moment it was a
momentous
joyous moment when it happened but i
felt sorry for y'all because i knew you
all couldn't celebrate the same way well
that's the problem is uh people
momentarily forgot about kovid yeah when
biden won
they literally they conan they act like
after the election
covet was like oh oh yeah my job is done
i'm out of here that's not what happened
cover was like oh y'all think i'm a hoax
oh okay well you get covey you get
covered everybody gets covey covert is
basically like oprah the way he just
touched people
i put coven under your seat you can
check it
yeah it was yeah i was i felt sorry for
you all that you all couldn't
couldn't hug and and be intimate like we
were